how's it going everybody so not too long
ago we received a leak that told us that
there's going to be a second villain in
Avengers 4
the leak was very legitimate and seems
to make a lot of sense the leak says
that there's going to be a second
villain in Avengers 4 that poses a
greater threat than even Thanos does
right now the most popular theory going
around is that a nihilist is actually
going to be the second villain and that
he's going to be inside of the quantum
realm but what if this isn't the case
what if the second villain isn't
Annihilus there's a lot of things that
make Annihilus very dangerous but if
Thanos even has a few of the Infinity
stones he's probably stronger than
Annihilus so who could be stronger than
that os-- and have a problem with the
snap well I'm taking this one right from
the comics and I'm going to say eternity
I'm still giving away copies of infinity
war and ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray
and some special edition posters if you
would like to enter the giveaway all you
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so in the Infinity
Gauntlet saga in the comics Danos gets
the Infinity Gauntlet with all of the
stones and does the snap Thanos with all
of the Infinity stones in the Infinity
Gauntlet basically has control over the
whole entire universe eternity is the
actual embodiment of all that there is
in the universe so he's very threatened
by Thanos's ability to control the
universe what happens is there is a
cosmic summit with all of the cosmic
entities and what happens is eternity
seeks judgment from the Living Tribunal
to stop Thanos eternity says to the
Living Tribunal the mad Titan seeks to
unbalance that which is throw the nature
of the universe into a maniac called
entropy but the Living Tribunal chooses
not to interfere stating that Thanos
only strives to replace eternity is
importance in the universe with his own
he then goes on to say that natural
selection is one of the universe's
oldest canons the strong replace the
weak it is as it should be no cosmic
crime is being committed eternity then
leaves and he leaves the rest of the
cosmic entities to fight against Thanos
once they fall eternity shows up to take
on tano's himself stating that he's
there to reclaim that which is
and myself control of this reality and
from there the two of them fight it out
so eternity is clearly affected by the
snap so it makes sense that the snap
itself would cause eternity to present
itself and appear and this is where it
could get tricky for our heroes as well
if you turn and Eve use the Infinity
stones as a threat it will most likely
seek to destroy the users of the
Infinity stones along with the stones as
well and since our heroes have been in
possession of Infinity stones and have
been fighting Thanos for the Infinity
stones eternity could very well perceive
them as a threat as far as second
villains showing up in Avengers for
eternity certainly fits the bill he is
every living thing and every living
thing is him thus he controls everything
in all planes of existence sothe Ana's
wiping out half of the universe from
existence would certainly make eternity
appear and as a cosmic entity he's more
powerful than Thanos although Thanos
ultimately has unlimited power with the
Infinity Gauntlet we know that it is
permanently damaged
and if eternity views our heroes as a
threat they could possibly have to team
up with feyo's to stop eternity
something that would personally love to
see on screen but this is just a theory
there are definitely a lot of reasons
why eternity could be the second villain
in Avengers 4 but let me know your
thoughts in the comments below do you
think he could show up in the next
Avengers movie or do you think it's
going to be a different villain let me
know and don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to
Avengers 4 as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]